to start off I went ahead and created
all the variables that I knew I would
need I needed family one family two
Bruce
Madison and Hunter four family to Bruce
Madison and Hunter I went ahead and
passed in a string of an HTML element to
the jQuery object this creates a new Dom
element I made sure to include these h1
h2 and h3 tags so I would know what I
was looking at when I saw the page after
that it was a simple matter of inserting
family two after family one appending
Bruce to family - and then Madison and
Hunter - Bruce but I want you to take a
look at the syntax of insert after
because it's a little different than
what we've seen before with jQuery
insert after acts on some Dom element
and then inserts it after the target I
also want you to notice that we could
have used this command called after
instead after follows more normal jQuery
syntax it acts on a selector and then
add some content after it we can go
ahead and check our work by looking at
the resulting page which looks pretty
good and we can open up dev tools to
make sure that the Dom is the way we'd
expect it to look